Một khi nhắc đến công nghệ NFC để cũng là bằng khoảng phổ biến của nhiều người.
Lếu chỉ một cuối chảm có khi những điều cã nhân bị đánh khắp.
Thật tế, đây là một trong những hiểu lòng phổ biến về công nghệ này.
NFC là vi tác của near-view communication, hát còn gọi là công nghệ,
kết nối không dây thầm gần.
Công nghệ này chỉ hoặc động khi người dùng chú đồng nước điểm thoại đến gần thịt về trong phạm vi rất nhắn,
và điểm thoại có hỗ trợ NFC.
Chỉ với thật tạm, NFC không tử động truy cập hay thu thật y liệu cá nhân.
Thích về chỉ kết hoặc nối dùng đã được có hình sẵn,
chẳng hàng nhiều mở quếp sai, hính thị thông tình sẵn phẩm, nhận u rải,
hoặc kết nối đến một chuyên trên tử tạm.
Mọi thật tế theo bao gồm vì công cấp không tinh,
đều gió người dùng chủ động quyết định.
Hình thẳng thẳng ấy từ một liên phát quan cảo thần một liên giảm tương tạm.
Cết nối liên mặt ý một chuyên ngoài tuy và một chuyên số.
Yipped thương hiểu rức nhắn quan cắt từ giù ý từng tạm đến chuyên đổi.